well this is a different view I'm
usually sitting all the way on the other
side of this room and now I'm sitting
here on this side of the room good
morning John it's Tetris day
what does Tetris day yeah I wanted to
show you guys this is a birthday present
from I've forgotten who hold on it was
from Helen Thank You Helen
today is Tetris day because together
we're going to do an awesome Tetris
related thing right now for those of you
who've been participating in the email
version of this project that's right
there's and stuff going on behind the
scenes if you've said stuff and already
it's definitely going to get used but we
need more we need a lot more now many of
you might know that I wrote a Tetris
song once it called the man who threw
the tetris piece I played it on my
acoustic guitar and an awesome
nerdfighter named Bill Martin who is dr.
noise do ctor noise he covered the song
that airy sort of hardcore fashion cue
music
[Music]
so that's gonna be the macker another
whole video so you can listen to do it
I'll bill and I have decided that we
would have make a nerd fight a stick
music video for his version of the
Tetris view song and we need your help
we need your help we need your help
really bad we're all gonna create Tetris
pieces in our own houses Tetris pieces
are all composed of squares each one has
four squares the squares in these
tensions pieces will be about eight
inches
nothing has to be perfect here really
don't be perfect be fast be awesome be
creative and be excited I'm gonna create
the tetris pieces and the nerdfighters
from all over the world will pretend
like they're playing Tetris and then
suddenly from out of their TV will pop
these Tetris pieces now I'm gonna show
you an example of how this might look
you can do it your own way but this is
how Katherine and I put it together
now I'm gonna tell you how to make the
tetris pieces scissors tape of some kind
of video camera tape measurers good a
straight edge construction paper of very
cars sharpie also it occurs to me that
you will need permission from your
parents to use the knife don't stain any
of your belongings with
[Music]
and once you've got you touches that
he'll finished please send it to dr.
noise at gmail.com the deadline for
submissions is June 14 June June 14 in
addition to playing Tetris and getting
hit by tetris pieces there are some
other things that you can do we're
trying to get lip-syncing for the whole
song but instead of having every member
eyes the whole song we decided to use a
mathematical formula to determine what
people have seeing what verses so if you
are going to do a video check out the
lyrics in the sidebar along with a
fairly basic mathematical formula that
will tell you which verse to memorize
and sing while you're playing Tetris /
dancing / getting from the face the
camera slap being in general shocked and
disturbed and frustrated with the
tenacity of the tetris man thank you to
everyone who could participate sment
thank you to bill for making the
excellent song and thank you to russia
for making tetris and also the tetris
song which thankfully is a folk melody
and that's not protected under US
copyright whoo nerdfighters John I will
see you soon